we've been doing too many violent films
lately so here comes Herby baby the
protagonist of the movie is a white
Volkswagen Beetle named Herby it is a
special car which has a brain of its own
and can interact like humans a few
months ago it had taken the racing World
by storm despite being significantly
smaller and weaker than other racing
cars Herby won all the competitions it
participated in however age finally
caught up to it after a few accidents
Herby struggled in some important races
and as as a result it was sold to a
junkyard where it got addicted to diesel
later we see it arriving at the place in
a trailer the owner of the junkyard Dave
believes that it is old and useless so
he decides to demolish it however Herby
doesn't like the idea in order to
dissuade him it starts playing several
pranks on him first it releases gas on
Dave's face and then pours oil on his
expensive shoes these pranks are
hardcore Herby even throws some of his
Parts onto the man to annoy him Des
despite the weirdness of the situation
Dave and his employees are not going to
give up so easily they try to grab Herby
by its chains and take it to the
shredder but it proves to be an
impossible task because Herby is a car
when the men get tired Herby seizes the
opportunity to escape but it doesn't
reach far as its old and Rusty tires
give out Dave who is now impressed by
The Beatles resilience decides against
demolishing it the scene then cuts to a
graduation ceremony where hundreds of
students are present Maggie p is one of
them and her dad Ray senior is extremely
proud of her he says that she is the
first one in the family to graduate from
college as the two engage in
conversation we get to know that
Maggie's entire family is invested in
car racing her grandfather was a legend
of his time while her brother is a
struggling racer who is trying his best
to make it into NASCAR wo sorry Instinct
during her college Years Maggie also
dreamt of becoming a racer one day but
that all changed when she was involved
in a minor accident now her father
father has strictly forbidden her from
racing he is instead focusing on
grooming his son Ray Jr for the upcoming
Nascar event unfortunately the ladder
isn't very good at the sport and he
usually ends up crashing his car what a
disappointment he is the following day
Ray Senor decides to give his daughter a
car as a graduation present but since he
cannot afford a new one he takes her to
the junkyard as soon as Herby spots the
girl he decides that he wants to go with
her Herby is down bad hopefully he
doesn't give her Herby to make this
happen he pulls out every trick in his
bag however she still doesn't notice him
Maggie instead chooses a Nissan car as
she likes its design after a while Herby
is lifted by a crane to be transported
elsewhere at the same time Maggie is on
the verge of sealing the deal for her
new car Herby doesn't like this so he
strategically falls on top of the Nissan
destroying it completely this leaves
Maggie with no choice but to go for the
Volkswagen Beetle instead following this
she gets inside the car and and starts
inspecting it all of a sudden the glove
compartment opens by itself and reveals
a note inside it is from the previous
owner which says to take care of Herby
Maggie then turns on the engine and as
soon as she does so Herby begins driving
on his own it turns and swerves in a
reckless manner causing her to scream in
Terror after a while it takes her to the
local garage which is owned by a guy
named Andy turns out he and Maggie used
to be friends in school Andy quit his
studies to support his family while
Maggie pursued college and eventually
graduated he is seeing her after a long
time and it's evident that he likes her
Herby thinks about committing vehicular
manslaughter and he offers to refurbish
the old car but for that he needs to
check it out first the two friends then
get inside the vehicle hoping to have a
normal ride but just like the last time
Herby goes crazy and starts driving on
its own this time it even showcases some
impressive stunts by driving on its rear
wheels soon the group accidentally ends
up in a sports car exhibition trip the
reigning NASCAR champion is giving out
autographs to his fans he appears to be
a national hero who is looking forward
to winning this season as well in the
meantime Herby keeps honking because
he's horny and he wants Maggie to drive
him away however this only annoys her so
she decides to turn it off she tries to
unplug some wires at the back but Herby
retaliates by spraying oil on her
clothes luckily Andy finds some racing
gear in the car's trunk which Maggie
reluctantly puts on shortly after trip
spots the Beetle and mocks its
appearance he jokingly asks Maggie to
return it to the circus where it came
from Herby says I'm not from a circus
I'm from a dump hearing this Herby is
enraged so it scratches trips expensive
car with its rear mirror this act
baffles the fans and they ask trip to
teach the driver a lesson they are
unaware that the car is actually driving
on its own Maggie desperately tries to
get out to apologize but Herby locks all
the windows and proceeds to the start
line soon the race begins and Herby's
gears start moving at a rapid Pace it
then takes off on its own scaring the
life out of Maggie at first both the
participants go toe-to-toe with each
other but trip soon uses his dirty
tactics to derail Herby off the course
this anger Maggie and she finally
decides to team up with the beetle the
ladder also allows her to take control
and together they catch up with trip in
no time despite being an old and Rusty
car Herby seems to be very fast it also
uses some unorthodox Maneuvers to dodge
Trip's attacks during the final moments
of the race Herby cleverly climbs onto
the safety bar and secures the victory
Volkswagen Beetle more like Volkswagen
she this shocks the entire crowd as
NASCAR champion trip has lost to an
unknown person in a beetle that's so
embarrassing they should probably kill
him the following day at home Maggie
overhears her father shouting at her
brother it turns out the ladder has lost
yet another sponsor due to his poor
performance at this rate the family is
going bankrupt because they have no
other source of income after a while Ray
Junior's final sponsor Sally shows up in
her yellow VC Beetle when Herby spots
the car it is instantly smitten now
she's got some junk in her trunk
meanwhile Sally shows Ray senior some
footage which turns out to be of the
same race from yesterday she points out
how the white beetle outclassed a NASCAR
champion at first Ray Senor is happy
because notices that the car is the same
one he bought a few days ago but then he
becomes disappointed that his daughter
has started racing again when he
confronts her about it Maggie cleverly
lies that it was her friend Max who was
driving the car in reality Max was just
an imaginary guy but he quickly goes
viral because of his supposed win over
trip on the other hand we see that trip
is still reeling from the loss his
assistant tries to make him understand
that street races aren't important but
trip Wants Revenge he then asks his team
to organize a two-day compet comptition
knowing that it will lure max out
meanwhile as Andy and Maggie are
spending some time in the garage they
come across an advertisement for an
upcoming competition the reward is a
whopping
$10,000 which adjusted for inflation is
like 3 billion this excites Andy and he
requests Maggie to give it a thought he
also offers to refurbish Herby with his
personal earnings if they win the
competition they will split the cash
prize in half Maggie is still hesitant
about the idea as she had promised her
father father that she would never drive
again but also because 50/50 is
but then she remembers that her family's
going through a hard time financially
this ultimately persuades her to race
again following this Andy immediately
gets to work on Herby he removes the old
rusty parts and replaces them with new
ones he also Paints the beetle to give
it a fresh look after the process is
complete Herby looks bang it's
surprising that her's a car because he's
looking busing after the process is
complete Maggie starts training for the
the big day the scene then cuts to the
day of the competition where a large
crowd is gathered when trip notices the
refurbished Beetle he gets a bit anxious
he later approaches Maggie and asks her
where she met the driver Max however she
completely changes the topic and leaves
after a while she Don her race gear and
sneaks inside the car the competition
rules are then announced for the first
phase the drivers will be competing
against each other the winner of this
phase will get to compete with trip the
next day soon the race begins and the
participants struggle to claim the top
spot they push each other use dirty
tactics and even resort to violence but
in the end the partnership of Herby and
Maggie manages to win the race in the
next scene a Restless trip is seen
researching The Mysterious Beetle when
he Zooms in he notices that the driver
has long red hair this makes him realize
that Max is hot but also that Max is
probably just a pseudonym and it was
Maggie driving the car all along that
night he meets her outside her room and
engages in conversation he then hands
her his sports car keys allowing her to
ride it as soon as he departs trip tries
to tamper with Herby but the VW Beetle
sprays oil all over his face foiling his
plans a while later Maggie returns with
the sports car and trip decides to raise
the stakes for tomorrow he proposes that
whoever wins the race will take the
loser's car in addition to the 10 grand
Maggie who is desperate for the money
immediately agrees she is confident that
Herby will show his usual Antics and win
the race for them unfortunately the
beetle overhears their conversation and
feels betrayed it feels like Maggie is
only using it for her gain so the next
day Herby decides to teach her a lesson
as the final race begins it takes a
significant lead and the crowd believes
that Max is going to win however just
before they reach the Finish Line Herby
abruptly stops Maggie tries her best to
operate the beetle but it just won't
move unfortunately trip takes full
advantage of this and wins the race he
then approaches Maggie and asks her to
reveal her face to everyone humiliated
and left with no options she obliges
Maggie's dad who is in the audience is
shocked to see her there 10 times out of
10 this guy would be stoked that his
daughter was driving so well but instead
he chastises her for breaking her
promise before storming away after a
while Andy approaches Maggie to console
her but trip interrupts their
conversation and reminds her about the
bet they made last night he then says
that he is taking the beetle away with
him hearing this Andy feels betrayed as
Maggie made this decision without
consulting him hence he also storms away
in the aftermath of these events Maggie
is on her way home with her best friend
she is completely broken and doesn't
know what to do just then it strikes her
that she lost the race because she had
tricked Herby had she not made the bet
they would have won the race already
hence she decides to make it up to Herby
by rescuing it through trip she learns
that the car car is about to be
destroyed in a monster truck competition
so she rushes to the arena and gets on
the field it is a very risky move as
Maggie could easily be crushed by the
giant trucks but she is determined to
save her best friend when Herby notices
her he comes back to life and
immediately Springs into action he
throws away his current driver who is
immediately run over by another truck
and then saves her from an approaching
truck after Maggie is in the driver's
seat they destroy some of the monster
trucks before making their escape in the
next scene they arrive at Andy's
workshop and he is taken aback to see
the car's condition nonetheless he
forgives Maggie and the two friends
reconcile Andy also promises to fix the
car for her the next day Maggie and her
family go to watch Ray Junior's practice
for the upcoming NASCAR competition
however he performs poorly and ends up
getting into yet another accident this
time it is serious as the doctor informs
him that his eyesight has been affected
now with Ray Jor ruled out of Sunday's
big race he pleads with his father to
let Maggie take his place however Ray
senior vehemently refuses stating that
he is not willing to take that risk Ray
senior is the one with the eye troubles
that night Maggie is at Andy's Workshop
discussing their current situation she
still wants to take part in the
competition but Herby is totally banged
up and needs a lot of repairs Andy
unfortunately doesn't have the funds to
order the new parts just then Ray junor
arrives at the garage with his entire
team they quickly get to work on Herby
and overnight the white VW Beetle is
refurbished into a brand new racing car
the scene then cuts to the race day
which is being broadcast live on
television you're telling me the other
ones weren't as trip is giving an
interview he spots the white beetle and
gets anxious he asks his men why they
didn't destroy the car but they reassure
him that it's of no threat soon the race
begins and all the cars accelerate at
their top speeds when Ray senior spots
his daughter on the television he gets
initially nervous but seeing her
performing so well he decides to head to
the venue to cheer for her meanwhile the
race has reached an exciting Point
several cars have ganged up on Herby and
are stopping its progress this
frustrates Maggie but as soon as she is
about to give up she hears her father's
voice on the radio he motivates her to
keep going as he believes that she can
win it unlike his failure of a son
hearing this both Maggie and Herby are
riled up and they become determined to
win the race to get out of the tricky
situation her climbs on top of a car and
drives over it now with only half a lap
remaining trip and Maggie are tussling
with each other for the top spot trip
once again resorts to cheating and
continuously Rams Herby with his car but
at one point the beetle moves out of the
way causing trip to strike the wall this
causes his vehicle to flip over and get
into an accident yes probably broke some
bones yes yes Herby is meters away from
crashing against the car but it
miraculously drives on the fence and
secures the Victory with this Maggie
becomes the first female to win a NASCAR
championship she celebrates with her
family and friends while an injured trip
complains that the beetle is alive Andy
also expresses his love for Maggie and
the two finally kiss the movie ends as
Herby finds the love of his life the
yellow Volkswagen Beetle subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching